Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis là, mais je ne suis pas là.
En réalité au moment où vous voyez cette vidéo il est 11H du matin, et moi je suis dans le train pour Amsterdam.
Je vais jouer à Amsterdam ce soir donc j'ai préparé la vidéo là, juste que vous voyez ici, hier soir.
Je vous ai dit hier si vous avez regardé la vidéo, aujourd'hui il y aurait un rapport avec quelque chose que j'ai découvert et une énigme.
Je vais vous le dire dans quelques secondes.
Générique !
[musique]
Il y a quelques temps sur Internet j'ai découvert un truc un peu ouf, que j'ai trouvé génial, c'est fait par les éditions du trésor, c'est un livre d'énigmes,
qui te permet,
de gagner un trésor !
Et je me suis dit, les mecs c'est énorme ! Ils ont poussé le truc hyper loin.
Donc je les ai contacté et je leur ai dit: "Ecoutez si vous voulez je fais une vidéo sur le projet, mais vous vous créez une énigme pour la chaine, et quand le livre sortira, j'aimerai bien avoir quelques exemplaires pour l'offrir aux abonnés".
Ils m'ont dit qu'ils étaient OK.
Et ils m'ont envoyé toute une énigme que j'ai un petit peu remixé aussi à ma sauce.
C'est une énigme en deux parties, ce n'est pas un placement de produit il n'y a pas de partenariat derrière, c'est juste un coup de coeur que j'ai eu pour ça et je suis très content aujourd'hui de vous mettre au défi.
Ils ont créé pour la chaine deux énigmes.
Une un petit peu plus dans le calcul et une un petit peu plus littéraire.
Quand j'ai vu celle sur le calcul, je me suis dis mais attends ils ne connaissent pas mes abonnés, ça, ils vont tout trouver trop facilement.
Pour ça je vous recommande de prendre un papier et un crayon pour la première, ou alors de prendre votre téléphone et de le mettre en mode calculatrice.
Après vous pouvez le faire de tete, mais il y a un risque d'erreurs dans ce cas là.
Vous prenez votre année de naissance, sauf si votre année de naissance est un palindrome.
Un palindrome c'est quelque chose qui se lit dans les deux sens.
Comme "Bob", Bob, boB, Bob, boB.
Donc si vous etes né en 1991 ou en 2332, déjà ça voudrait dire que Youtube existe toujours et que mes vidéos sont encore regardées... c'est sympa !
Mais surtout c'est une année palindrome, donc il faut que vous preniez l'année de quelqu'un d'autre, d'un pote, de votre frère, de votre soeur...
Première étape, vous mettez les chiffres de l'année à l'envers.
Par exemple je suis né en 1982, donc moi ça donne 2,8,9,1.
2891.
Deuxième étape, vous soutreyez le chiffre de votre année de naissance. Donc moi je vais faire 1982-2891.
Que le résultat soit positif ou négatif, on s'en fiche, on s'en fiche de la polarité en fait de ce résultat.
Et pour terminer vous pratiquez une réduction comme ceci, une grosse réduction.
La réduction c'est d'additionner les chiffres qui composent ce nombre jusqu'à temps qu'il ne reste plus qu'un seul chiffre.
Par exemple mon résultat à moi c'est -909.
Mais le moins on s'en fiche, donc c'est 909.
Ca fait 9+0+9, ça fait 18.
Mais dans 18 il y a encore deux chiffres, donc je vais faire 1+8 et ça me fait 9.
Est-ce que vous etes toujours là ?
Et bien voici la dernière étape. La dernière étape c'est que vous allez ajouter à votre résultat, (à la réduction que vous venez de faire), le nombre d'étapes qu'on vient de faire pour cette première énigme.
Et c'est la première partie de l'indice de l'énigme finale.
Je vais quand meme vous donner un petit indice...
Le résultat ça fait partie de la suite de Fibonacci.
Et ça, ça fait plaisir comment indice hein ?!
Disons que si vous etes triskaïdékaphobe, vous n'allez pas aimer ce résultat là.
Alors on passe à la deuxième énigme qui va vous fournir également la fin de la solution de l'énigme globale.
Et ça c'est plus avec les mots et les lettres.
Ils ont mélangé la charade et le rébus.
Le système des charades c'est mon premier... mon second... et mon tout... etc...
Et bien c'est exactement ça avec un rébus.
Alors voici mon premier: (je ne vous le mets pas non plus durant des heures, vous n'avez juste à mettre "pause" pour prendre le temps de le déchiffrer):
[image]
Mon second vous est donné par un rébus équation, le voici:
(meme principe pour tout à l'heure, mettez "pause" pour le chercher):
[image]
Et mon tout précède mon second et mon premier dans un célèbre phrase mnémotechnique qu'on m'a souvent répété quand j'étais à l'école.
Surtout à moi...
Attention, sauf pour nos amis québecois qui n'ont pas la meme phrase mnémotechnique , dans ce cas là pour vous: mon tout suis mon second et mon premier.
Et maintenant la synthèse, l'énigme globale !
Si vous combinez la réponse à la première énigme (celle qui était sur les chiffres), avec la réponse de la deuxième énigme, alors vous avez trouvé le mot clé final !
A quoi il sert le mot clé final ?
Alors là pour l'instant il ne vous sert à rien.
A part à vous amuser.
Je vous donnerai la solution demain, j'imagine qu'il y en a qui ne pourront pas s'empecher dans la mettre dans les commentaires.
Merci à ceux qui ne l'auront pas fait, de jouer le jeu, évitez de le mettre si ça vous démange...
Par contre vous pouvez vous donner des petits indices entre vous, ça c'est beaucoup plus cool.
Je vous le rappelle, ce n'est pas moi qui ai créé ces énigmes.
Merci à toute l'équipe du trésor perdu que j'ai contacté, je trouve leur projet hyper ambitieux et c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu faire une vidéo sur eux.
Ils sortent un livre d'énigmes "Trésor perdu", qui est une chasse au trésor en France.
Il y a 11 énigmes qui ont été écrites par un mystérieux libraire et il y a un vrai petit coffret avec l'équivalent de 50 000 euros à l'intérieur en pièces d'or et en emmeraudes qu'on peut retrouver si on arrive à résoudre le livre.
Il n'y a pas 1 coffret par livre !
Et pour éditer le livre ils ont créé un kisskissbankbank qui s’arrête le 6. Le 6 de ce mois-ci, là.
Si vous voulez le précommander je vous mets le lien dans la description.
Et ça vous permettra de l'avoir un petit peu moins cher, un petit peu avant sa sortie en librairie et même d'avoir une édition limitée avec des indices.
Si ça vous tente aussi j'ai vu qu'il y en a qui faisaient ça, ils se constituent en équipe pour essayer de chercher le trésor.
Donc vous pouvez constituer l'équipe des Mentalos, je ne m'en occuperai pas mais voilà je vous le dis, si jamais quelqu'un veut gérer ça et essayer de constituer une team pour trouver le trésor...
Faites, les amis !
Le lien est dans la description, vous vous êtes devant l'écran.
N'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo, également à vous abonner.
Et rendez-vous demain matin à 11H.
Je vous donnerai en meme temps la solution.
Ciao !
[musique]